So interestingly enough, there's not
actually that much to cover from CPAC,
the Conservative Political Action Conference.
We covered Donald Trump's speech
earlier in the show. And there's only a few other
things to say of CPAC. You know, at one point,
CPAC really was one of the more important right
wing conferences with many big players from the
American right. And this past weekend, CPAC
was more like a racist, trans phobic religious
Comic-Con than a serious gathering. And I don't
even want to insult con like comparing CPAC to
Comic-Con. Comic-Con has a lot of really
interesting things. Comic-Con has lots of
great sci fi writers and a lot of interesting
things. I think I would learn a lot more actually
by going to Comic-Con than I would from CPAC. So
I'll put it a different way. I would much rather
go to Comic-Con than CPAC. Not only would it
be more informative, I'd meet more interesting
people and people more grounded in reality. In
any case, Comic-Con sort of analogy's aside.
One of the notable speeches was Ted Cruz. Ted
Cruz is the now very much beleaguered senator
who recently had had to cut his Cancun vacation
short because it exploded into a public relations
nightmare when he fled to Mexico with his family
as his own constituents in Texas were without
power, sometimes without heat, struggling
even to get food. Water had to be boiled
many times with electricity they didn't have.
Ted Cruz went to Cancun. So Ted Cruz goes to CPAC
and he appeared to have sort of like a manic
episode. His speech ended with a completely
hyperbolic crescendo of screaming, which we'll
get to. But Ted Cruz first opening with a joke
about wanting to be back in Cancun.
I guess God bless CPAC.
I got to say, Orlando is awesome.
It's not as nice as Cancun.
But it's nice, so really well crafted comedy by
the Republican senator, really a wordsmith and
public speaking expert, as you can see. Then he
ridiculously went after Senator Bernie Sanders and
Congresswoman Alexandrea a Cassio Cortez. We're
actually going to come back to the AOC part a
little bit later. But take a look.
Bernie. Is wearing mittens.
And AOC is telling us she was murdered.
And the media desperately, desperately,
desperately wants to see a Republican civil war.
So this is like I can't figure out if this
is bad comedy or terrible political speech. I
actually can't tell which it is. Maybe it's both
Ted Cruz then going into an anti mask
rant. They're still on this mask stuff.
By the way, how many of you all have eaten
at a restaurant in the last six months?
Can I just stop and say how strange the rules
are right now? I want to understand how this
virus works. So when you walk in, you've
got to put your mask on. Sadly, I've got to.
You walk in, you got to put your mask
on. You sit down, you take your mask off.
See, apparently the virus is
actually connected elevation.
Now, remember, this is all about science, it's
actually it may not be elevation, I think it's
it's that there are hormones that are
released in your thighs when you're sitting.
So you can sit at the table.
There's no virus being transmitted.
But if you stand up, put the mask on,
who wrote this stuff for Ted Cruz,
they should really be writing for SNL or The Daily
Show. I mean, great, great material for how you
would ridicule a politician giving a speech.
And then here is where Ted Cruz starts to kind
of escalate and seemingly get more and more manic.
Well, they're saying everybody can get immunized.
We can have herd immunity everywhere and we're
going to wear masks for the next 300 years.
And by the way, not just one, two, three,
four. You can't have too many masks.
How much virtue do you want to signal?
This is just dumb.
Ted Cruz working himself up to actually being
sort of short of breath now, and of course,
as I've said many times before, the reason that
public health experts have to be so cautious in
what they say about what an individual getting
vaccinated means is that so many people like Ted
Cruz, like his followers, like the people at CPAC,
they are desperate to disregard all guidelines and
measured measures. Oh, one person got vaccinated.
Let's hold a 50 person indoor party. Of course,
reasonable people know that vaccination opens
new doors for people. And of course, as more
people get vaccinated, we will be able to start
backing off of all the guidelines. But because
of people like Ted Cruz spreading disinformation
that we never needed masks and all of this stuff
all along was bogus. Public health experts have to
say just because you got vaccinated, don't go nuts
just because five percent of the population has
had two doses or whatever the number is, I'm not
cut up. We'll have a report tomorrow. Doesn't
mean everything can be disregarded. Ted Cruz now
is and I've seen, unfortunately, Facebook friends
posting this, too. If the vaccines change nothing,
why would I get a vaccine? And, of course, as
we talked about last week in our segment about
vaccine alarmism, that's not the case. But the
reason people have to continue being so careful
with what they say from a public health standpoint
is because of people like Ted Cruz. OK, I'll
interrupt this rant and do more of it tomorrow.
Then here's the absolute end to Ted Cruz's speech,
screaming at the top of his lungs
and really appearing to lose it,
in the immortal words of William Wallace.
So that's a senator, one of 100 senators
in the collegial and storied legislative
body. That is the United States government,
the United States Senate within the United States
government, screaming at the top of his lungs,
quoting Mel Gibson in Braveheart as an apparently
defiant and principled stand against wearing
a mask during a pandemic. This was one of
the highlights of CPAC, if you can imagine
most of the rest of it not even worth covering.
But one theme that we did see throughout CPAC
is the inability to accept that Donald Trump
lost. And I want to talk about that next.